yeah welcome to this video playing pop
whirl pop hole and this yeah Poland the
Catalan or the Queens gambit let's play
the cat alone yeah this is one of the
sharper lines where blackham is trying
to keep the pawn and quite often manages
to to do so but often at the expense of
some quite dangerous initiative I just
blundered deform but I hope if enough
play this was really too quick we take
special p to her maybe maybe this is
this is some comp
ya see success probably protect
yeah I'm not really threatening to take
okay what is to be played now I go I can
I can do this first and see if he goes
Quinn be formed it doesn't so boxy one
threatening should be a 3 now
hmm
and let's just continue to develop him
it's no use to even spend more time it's
how to determine anyway what's the best
compensation type of position sem wow
hmm
this looks like there should be some
tactic
hmm I don't see it
isn't there tactic come on through q1
and something okay let's see it they do
this first bishop age 7 some some
background stuff
I don't see anything
don't see I don't see it is there
something Bishop here night f7 scandal
stuff I don't wait wait wait wait wait
anoop the eighth is this I'm sacrificing
really a lot here maybe too much why is
he thinking about something else
lynbrook f7
or is it or is it just Queen g6 and as
after weighing all so this could be one
general problem with this besides the
fact that I'm sacrificing a whole lot
here okay mpm this is also a problem
that's really a lot that I'm giving up
here it's probably an open probably too
much check
yeah this is just bad night tonight
somewhere also would have been good my g
six or something
it probably can play book night g6 on 97
or this one oh it says of this is what
this is some some nice pins here and old
thank you just he just blended it away
quite lucky for me can you somehow
continue I don't know c3 or something
yeah it's am I can take p3 and SL that's
too much yeah very lucky very lucky for
me this didn't work at all but it looked
so so tempting to UM to sacrifice
there's no way to defend design yeah
quite lucky let's examine this position
for a while is there something the
computer and it's just on 000 with 23
there this is the same move just trying
to improve maybe the bishop check also
000 yeah this is simply losing it's not
it's not working at all and I wasn't
even sure if I'm look f8 something but
now that I see I see better can do that
so I needs to do that ok Queen takes
yeah and this is just winning from zero
point of view
it's it's too much too much material
form for the Queen yeah he just blended
it away what can I say just be lucky
thanks for watching